it is amazing uh but the with the
weather and um the weather wasn't that
favorable uh but we we were able to
Summit
what was the most challenging part of it
for you Harry
ah there's so many it's just there's not
just one uh but there are so many just
going through the uh's fall the blue
eyes and uh the altitude and cold and
yeah there's so many
how long was the climb
from campho to camp for 25 hours 10
minutes oh my goodness me what were you
thinking about while you were climbing
um
yeah I was thinking and lots of things
just trying to focus one step at a time
but make sure you know teams are okay
we're all good all our oxygen is all um
you know enough to come down which which
wasn't uh
yeah and
that's just whether we're gonna reach
down the top and just thinking of the
last five years five years of hard work
and
um yeah just try to get on the top and
it makes it keeping all the teams safe
yeah you've certainly proven the people
who ban disabled people climbing wrong
haven't you
yes we did uh and I really appreciate
personally to you and uh there is a
manager journalists around the world
that who put a pressure on the Nepal
government
it's absolutely amazing what what do you
plan to do next
ah
um maybe it keep it keep continuously
um uh making awareness of disability and
sensing perception on persons with a
disability
and maybe I don't know but maybe promote
a piece because you know I went you know
I skipped the war in Nepal and I'm going
to fight another war and I think War
doesn't do good to anyone else and I
think
um maybe maybe take take some of the you
know friends that I fought and go to the
adventure together and also and also
um you know about two years I'm sitting
on in the tent here and about two inch
deep down here so you can see the effect
of the climate change in global warming
and this is just about a month we are
staying in here and I've been to uh club
twice and you know when I went last time
more than 20 meters of the ice is the
melted so I think we need to protect the
environment and Earth for our future
generation as well so I'll be advocating
it uh those things uh um as much as I
can rest of my life
amazing Harry
um safely back down again please and
come and see us when you are back in
London
I would love to come there and speak to
you thanks so much for having me thank
you and I really appreciated your
support
and as always thank you for your service
Harry thank you
thank you bye-bye bye bye
off he goes um so he lost both of his
legs and while fighting in Afghanistan
he is the first ever person to climb
Everest as a double amputee with his
amputations uh above his knee um he had
been banned as a disabled person from
climbing man's Everest but finally the
government has succumbed and so off he
went and he is the first ever person to
climb Mount Everest as a double amputee
with the amputation above the knee